bine ai revenit la Înțelegerea Informației și Computației Cuantice, numele meu este John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic pentru educație la IBM Quantum
aceasta este lecția a 13-a din serie și este prima lecție din al patrulea și ultimul modul, care tratează eroarea cuantică
corectarea erorilor cuantice Computația Cuantică are potențialul de a permite soluții eficiente pentru sarcini computaționale pentru care
algoritmii clasici eficienți nu sunt cunoscuți și posibil nu există există însă provocări foarte semnificative care
vor trebui depășite dacă dorim să implementăm tipurile de computații cuantice la scară largă pe care sperăm că într-o zi vor fi
posibile miezul problemei este că informația cuantică este extrem de fragilă poți literalmente să o strici doar prin
faptul că te uiți la ea și astfel pentru a funcționa corect calculatoarele cuantice trebuie să izoleze informația cuantică pe care o
stochează de mediul înconjurător la un grad extrem dar în același timp calculatorul cuantic însuși trebuie să ne ofere
un control foarte precis asupra acestei informații cuantice și asta include inițializarea corectă, operații unitare precise și fiabile
și bineînțeles capacitatea de a efectua măsurători astfel încât să putem obține de fapt rezultatele
computației există în mod clar o tensiune între aceste cerințe și în primele zile ale Computației Cuantice au existat unii care considerau că fragilitatea
informației cuantice și susceptibilitatea sa atât la inexactități cât și la zgomotul de mediu vor
face Computația Cuantică imposibilă astăzi există puține îndoieli că construirea unui
calculator cuantic precis, fiabil și la scară largă este o provocare monumentală dar avem un instrument cheie care să ne ajute în acest demers care îi face pe cei mai mulți
oameni care sunt informați despre domeniu să fie optimiști că Computația Cuantică la scară largă va deveni într-o zi realitate și acel instrument este eroarea cuantică
corectarea erorilor cuantice pentru următoarele patru lecții vom discuta despre corectarea erorilor cuantice cu accent pe
principii fundamentale în această lecție vom arunca o primă privire asupra corectării erorilor cuantice incluzând unul dintre primele coduri cuantice
corectoare de erori descoperite codul Shore de 9 qubiți și vom discuta și un alt Concept fundamental în
corectarea erorilor cuantice care este cunoscut drept discretizarea erorilor în lecțiile ulterioare ale modulului vom vedea construcții mai sofisticate și în cele din urmă mai bune
ale codurilor cuantice corectoare de erori și vom discuta și problema computației cuantice pe informația cuantică codificată folosind
componente computaționale care nu sunt ele însele perfecte și sunt predispuse la erori iată o scurtă prezentare a
lecției vom începe prin a discuta codurile de repetiție clasice care sunt poate cel mai simplu și mai de bază tip
de cod clasic corector de erori codurile de repetiție clasice nu sunt coduri deosebit de bune din perspectiva
teoriei codificării clasice cel puțin nu de unele singure dar asta e în regulă aici urmărim simplitatea și în special
vom arunca o privire la cel mai simplu cod clasic corector de erori pe care ți-l poți imagina pe care îl vom folosi apoi ca bază pentru un exemplu simplu
de cod cuantic corector de erori acel exemplu este codul Shore de 9 qubiți pe care îl vom discuta în detaliu
incluzând o descriere a codului în sine precum și proceduri pentru codificarea qubiților folosind acest cod detectarea erorilor pe qubiții codificați și
corectarea acelor erori și în a treia parte a lecției vom discuta discretizarea erorilor care ne permite să gândim despre erori arbitrare pe
qubiți care în principiu formează un Continuum de posibilități în termeni discreți reducând esențial erorile la
așa-numitele inversări de bit și inversări de fază înainte de a intra în detaliile tehnice ale corectării erorilor cuantice merită
să ne oprim un moment pentru a considera necesitatea corectării erorilor cuantice precum și a erorilor clasice
corectarea erorilor clasice după cum am sugerat la începutul lecției calculatoarele cuantice sunt foarte susceptibile la erori datorită
fragilității informației cuantice în special interacțiunile nedorite cu mediul sau cu
alte cuvinte cu restul lumii pot perturba informația cuantică aceste interacțiuni nedorite pot cauza decoerență unde informația
practic se scurge în mediu determinând informația stocată de calculatorul cuantic să se comporte din ce în ce mai mult
clasic este de asemenea critic important să recunoaștem că operațiile cuantice pot fi efectuate doar cu o precizie limitată
de exemplu am putea dori să efectuăm un anumit gate cuantic pe un qubit dar deoarece dispozitivele fizice nu sunt
niciodată perfecte ceea ce implementăm efectiv ar putea fi doar o aproximare a acelui gate asta ar putea să nu fie mare lucru pentru un
singur gate dar dacă intenția noastră este să efectuăm mii sau milioane de gate-uri cuantice aceste mici inexactități se vor
acumula și când computația se termină am putea ajunge cu o stare foarte diferită de ceea ce
ne-am așteptat deci aceasta este o sursă destul de diferită de erori dar cu siguranță una pe care nu putem să o
ignorăm oamenii studiază codurile clasice corectoare de erori de aproape un secol și aceste coduri au multe aplicații inclusiv în
transmiterea și stocarea informațiilor dar deoarece componentele computaționale clasice sunt atât de fiabile nu avem de fapt
nevoie de corectarea erorilor pentru a construi calculatoare clasice acum s-ar putea ca corectarea erorilor să nu fie necesară de fapt
pentru a construi calculatoare cuantice fiabile la scară largă de exemplu ideea principală din spatele Computației Cuantice Topologice
este că ar putea fi posibil să construiești sisteme cuantice robuste care sunt protejate intrinsec împotriva zgomotului datorită
proprietăților topologice ale sistemelor dar nu știm dacă acest lucru va fi posibil și se crede destul de larg
că corectarea erorilor va fi probabil esențială într-o formă sau alta pentru Computația Cuantică la scară largă acum vom discuta codurile de
repetiție clasice care formează baza pentru primul nostru cod cuantic corector de erori codul Shore de 9 qubiți pe care
îl vom vedea în curând codurile de repetiție sunt exemple extrem de de bază ale codurilor corectoare de erori
ideea este că putem proteja biții împotriva erorilor pur și simplu repetând fiecare bit de un anumit număr de ori în special să aruncăm o privire la
codul de repetiție pe trei biți aici codificăm un bit în trei pur și simplu repetând bitul de trei ori deci
zero este codificat ca 000 și unu este codificat ca 111 desigur dacă nu merge nimic prost
putem distinge cu ușurință cele două posibilități dar dacă a apărut o eroare și unul dintre biți s-a inversat să zicem
ceea ce înseamnă că un zero se schimbă într-un unu sau un unu se schimbă într-un zero atunci putem totuși să determinăm care a fost bitul original
văzând care dintre cele două valori binare apare de două ori în mod echivalent putem decoda calculând valoarea majoritară
sau cu alte cuvinte valoarea binară care apare cel mai frecvent și nu e greu să vedem că
dacă avem cel mult o eroare de inversare de bit atunci decodificarea va fi corectă desigur dacă doi biți se inversează sau dacă
toți trei biții se inversează atunci nu va funcționa și vom obține valoarea greșită când decodificăm și aceasta este o proprietate generală
pe care o posedă fiecare cod corector de erori s-ar putea să poți corecta unele erori dar nu vei putea niciodată corecta fiecare eroare și în cele din urmă este vorba de
a reduce șansa unei erori spre deosebire de a garanta corectitudinea ceea ce în general nu este
WEBVTT
posibil ca exemplu al unei situații în care putem reduce șansa de a face o eroare să presupunem că
scopul nostru este de a comunica un singur bit unui receptor ipotetic și pentru a face asta putem transmite biți printr-un
așa-numit Canal Simetric Binar care inversează fiecare bit transmis prin el independent cu o anumită probabilitate
P deci cu probabilitatea 1 minus P receptorul va primi bitul pe care am intenționat să îl trimitem dar cu probabilitatea P
bitul se inversează și receptorul primește valoarea opusă față de ceea ce am trimis deci dacă nu folosim codul de repetiție
și în schimb trimitem pur și simplu orice bit avem în minte prin canal receptorul va primi bitul greșit cu
probabilitatea p pe de altă parte dacă mai întâi codificăm bitul pe care vrem să îl trimitem folosind codul de repetiție pe trei biți și
apoi trimitem fiecare dintre cei trei biți ai codificării prin canal atunci fiecare dintre ei se inversează cu probabilitatea P deci
șansele unei inversări de bit sunt acum mai mari deoarece există acum trei biți care ar putea eventual să se inverseze în loc de unul
dar dacă cel mult unul dintre biți se inversează atunci receptorul va putea decoda corect deci vom obține o eroare abia după
decodificare dacă doi sau mai mulți biți se inversează în timpul transmisiei și nu e prea greu să calculăm că asta se întâmplă cu
probabilitatea 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P cub pentru valori ale lui P mai mici decât 1/12
aceasta duce la o scădere a probabilității că receptorul ajunge cu bitul greșit va exista în continuare o șansă de eroare în acest caz dar
codul scade probabilitatea acesteia și dacă ai vrea să scazi șansa și mai mult ai putea face asta folosind un
cod diferit incluzând dar fără a se limita la posibilitatea de a folosi un cod de repetiție unde bitul codificat este repetat
de mai mult de trei ori pentru valori ale lui P mai mari decât 1/12 apropo codul de fapt înrăutățește
lucrurile în sensul că crește probabilitatea ca receptorul să primească bitul greșit deci cu siguranță nu am folosi acest cod în acea
situație codul de repetiție pe trei biți este un cod clasic corector de erori dar putem considera și ce se întâmplă dacă
încercăm să îl folosim pentru a proteja qubiții împotriva erorilor nu este un cod cuantic corector de erori prea bun după cum vom vedea
poate corecta unele erori dar face alte erori mai probabile este totuși primul pas spre codul Shore
deci să vedem cum funcționează pentru qubiți mai întâi pentru a fi clar când ne referim la codul de repetiție pe 3 biți folosit
pentru qubiți ceea ce avem în minte este o codificare a unui qubit după cum este arătat pe ecran unde Alpha 0 plus beta 1 este
codificat ca Alpha 000 plus beta 111 sau cu alte cuvinte starea bazei standard
este repetată de trei ori observă în special că aceasta nu este același lucru cu repetarea stării cuantice de trei ori ca într-o
stare cuantică s codificată ca s tensor s tensor s ceea ce nu este o codificare pe care am putea-o
implementa pentru o stare cuantică necunoscută s prin teorema no-cloning codificarea despre care vorbim
pe de altă parte este foarte ușor de implementat iată un circuit cuantic foarte simplu care face asta folosind doi qubiți de spațiu de lucru inițializați și două
gate-uri controlled NOT acum să presupunem că o eroare are loc după ce codificarea a fost
efectuată și în special să presupunem că o operație Pauli X sau cu alte cuvinte o inversare de bit are loc pe unul
dintre qubiți și în această figură este qubitului din mijloc desigur aceasta nu este singurul tip de eroare care ar putea apărea și ai putea
obiecta la ideea că o eroare ia forma acestei operații unitare perfecte dar vom reveni la aceasta mai târziu în lecție și deocamdată putem
să o gândim pur și simplu ca pe un exemplu iată starea rezultată este aceeași cu codificarea originală cu excepția
că bitul din mijloc din fiecare ket a fost inversat în mod evident putem vedea asta din expresiile matematice pentru stare
dar să presupunem că aveam doar cei trei qubiți și că bănuiam că s-ar fi putut produce o inversare de bit dar nu știam care qubit ar fi putut fi
afectat o modalitate de a determina dacă a avut loc o inversare de bit ar fi să efectuăm o măsurătoare în baza standard și să examinăm rezultatul în acest caz am vedea
fie 010 fie 101 cu probabilități dependente de Alpha și beta și în ambele cazuri concluzia noastră
ar fi că bitul din mijloc s-a inversat dar din nefericire asta strică starea cuantică originală și această stare
ar putea fi prețioasă pentru noi la urma urmei întregul punct este de a proteja această stare cuantică deci aceasta nu este o
opțiune bună ceea ce putem face în schimb este să folosim circuit-ul cuantic arătat aici pe ecran unde introducem starea codificată
în cei mai de sus trei qubiți practic ce face circuit-ul este să calculeze paritatea stărilor
bazei standard pentru cei mai de sus doi qubiți precum și pentru cei mai de jos doi qubiți ai codificării și asta va dezvălui
locația inversării de bit în particular în acest caz vom obține rezultatul unu pentru ambele aceste verificări de paritate și din
acea informație putem concluziona că bitul din mijloc este cel diferit față de celelalte două deci acela este evident cel care
s-a inversat și crucial acest lucru nu determină colapsul stării deci avem acum o șansă să încercăm să corectăm această inversare de bit
astfel încât în cele din urmă să putem decodifica și să recuperăm starea originală vom reveni la corecție
imediat dar mai întâi să considerăm pe scurt celelalte posibilități pentru o eroare de inversare de bit Dacă în schimb eroarea de inversare de bit
a apărut pe qubitului de jos sau din stânga atunci am obține rezultatul unu zero citit de jos în sus și din nou
starea nu s-ar schimba și dacă inversarea de bit s-a întâmplat pe qubitului de sus atunci ieșirea ar fi
01 și din nou starea nu se schimbă și apropo dacă nu a existat
nicio eroare de inversare de bit atunci rezultatul măsurătorii este 00 și din nou starea rămâne nemodificată
deci să rezumăm toate acestea sub forma unui tabel unde listăm fiecare dintre stările posibile pe care le obținem din cel mult o inversare de bit măsurătoarea
al cărei rezultat îl numim sindrom în contextul corectării erorilor și corecția pe care trebuie să o facem pentru a recupera codificarea originală
dacă nu a existat nicio eroare sindromul este 00 și nu este nevoie să facem nimic pentru a repara
starea dacă qubitului de jos sau cel mai din stânga a suferit o inversare de bit sindromul este 10 și corecția corespunzătoare
este să aplicăm un gate X pe qubitului de jos sau cel mai din stânga și celelalte două cazuri sunt
similare deci dacă aplicăm corecția corespunzătoare pe baza sindromului atunci vom putea cu siguranță recupera codificarea originală
în toate cele patru cazuri din nou luăm în considerare doar posibilitatea că cel mult o
eroare de inversare de bit a apărut aceasta nu ar funcționa corect dacă doi sau trei biți s-ar inversa și nici nu am luat în considerare
posibilitatea altor erori acum să considerăm un tip diferit de eroare în domeniul cuantic inversările de bit
nu sunt singurele erori de care trebuie să ne îngrijorăm de exemplu trebuie să ne îngrijorăm și de inversările de fază
sau pur și simplu inversările de fază pe scurt care sunt descrise de gate-urile Z sau echivalent de matricile Pauli Z
WEBVTT
din nefericire codul de repetiție pe trei biți eșuează complet în a detecta inversările de fază de exemplu să presupunem că
codificăm un qubit folosind codul de repetiție pe 3 biți exact ca înainte și o eroare de inversare de fază apare pe qubitului din mijloc
vom obține starea arătată pe ecran care este exact codificarea pe care am fi obținut-o dacă o
inversare de fază s-ar fi întâmplat pe qubitului original înainte de a codifica și deci dacă efectuăm același
circuit ca înainte pentru a încerca să detectăm o eroare am obține sindromul 00 care sugerează greșit că nu au apărut erori
deci codul de repetiție pe 3 biți funcționează pentru cel mult o eroare de inversare de bit dar eșuează în a detecta erorile de inversare de fază în
fapt înrăutățește lucrurile într-un anumit sens deoarece acum avem de trei ori mai mulți qubiți care ar putea suferi inversări de fază
am observat că codul de repetiție pe trei biți este complet orbitor față de erorile de inversare de fază deci nu pare
prea util pentru a trata acest tip de eroare dar de fapt putem modifica codul de repetiție pe trei biți astfel încât
să detecteze erorile de inversare de fază și voi explica acum cum se poate face asta iată circuit-ul original pentru
codificarea unui qubit folosind codul de repetiție pe 3 biți și modul în care îl vom modifica este foarte simplu pur și simplu aplicăm un
gate Hadamard fiecărui qubit al codificării un gate Hadamard transformă starea zero într-o stare plus și starea unu
într-o stare minus astfel efectul net este că obținem starea arătată pe ecran unde ket
plus plus plus și ket minus minus minus sunt notații prescurtate pentru tensorul a trei stări plus sau a trei stări minus
o eroare de inversare de fază sau cu alte cuvinte un gate Z transformă stările plus în stări minus și stările minus în
stări plus deci această codificare va fi utilă pentru detectarea și corectarea erorilor de inversare de fază și pentru a face asta putem
modifica circuit-ul de detectare a erorilor din înainte în felul următor iată circuit-ul din înainte și ce vom face este
pur și simplu să punem gate-uri Hadamard atât la început cât și la sfârșit după cum este arătat pe ecran
ideea este foarte simplă primele trei gate-uri Hadamard transformă stările plus și minus înapoi în stări zero și unu
aceleași verificări de paritate ca înainte au loc și apoi al doilea strat de gate-uri Hadamard ne aduce înapoi la
codificarea noastră un alt mod de a gândi despre asta este că practic transformăm erorile de inversare de fază în erori de inversare de bit prin conjugare cu operații Hadamard
putem apropo simplifica circuit-ul puțin acest circuit de aici este complet echivalent
și poți verifica asta singur dacă ești dispus deci dacă introducem qubitului codificat în acest circuit presupunând
că nu au apărut erori de inversare de fază obținem sindromul 00 indicând că nu au existat erori de inversare de fază
și dacă avem o eroare de inversare de fază pe qubitului de sus să zicem atunci plusurile și minusurile din dreapta se inversează
și asta rezultă într-un sindrom de eroare diferit 01 în acest caz care identifică locația inversării de fază exact cum
am avut pentru inversarea de bit și putem atunci să o corectăm aplicând un gate Z pe qubitului de sus și situația
este similară pentru erorile de inversare de fază pe oricare dintre ceilalți doi qubiți deci putem de fapt detecta și
corecta până la o eroare de inversare de fază folosind acest cod dar din nefericire după cum ai putea ghici nu mai putem
corecta erorile de inversare de bit nu totul este pierdut totuși deoarece putem de fapt combina aceste două coduri
împreună pentru a obține un cod care poate corecta atât erorile de inversare de bit cât și cele de inversare de fază și de fapt va putea
corecta orice eroare pe un singur qubit este acum momentul să discutăm codul Shore de 9 qubiți care este un cod
cuantic corector de erori pe care îl putem obține combinând cele două coduri pe care tocmai le-am văzut adică codul de repetiție pe trei biți
care ne permite să corectăm o singură eroare de inversare de bit și versiunea modificată a acelui cod care ne permite să corectăm o singură inversare de fază
pentru a fi mai precis codul Shore de 9 qubiți este codul pe care îl obținem prin concatenarea celor două coduri ceea ce înseamnă
că mai întâi aplicăm o codificare care codifică un qubit în trei și apoi aplicăm cealaltă codificare fiecăruia dintre
cei trei qubiți separat deci vom obține nouă qubiți în total putem exprima asta sub forma unui
circuit diagram după cum urmează mai întâi vom aplica versiunea modificată a codului de repetiție pe 3 biți
care detectează erorile de inversare de fază și apoi vom codifica fiecare dintre qubiții rezultați independent folosind codul original
de repetiție pe 3 biți deci dacă reducem puțin acest circuit pentru a face mai mult spațiu putem
specifica codul în termeni oarecum diferiți descriind cum cele două stări ale bazei standard pentru qubitului nostru original sunt
codificate și odată ce știm asta putem determina prin linearitate cum un vector de stare cuantică arbitrar este
codificat deci acesta este codul Shore de 9 qubiți și ideea este că unul dintre coduri ne permite să corectăm erorile de inversare de fază
și celălalt cod ne permite să corectăm erorile de inversare de bit și după cum vom vedea asta va implica de fapt că putem
corecta o eroare arbitrară pe un singur qubit acum să vedem cum putem detecta și corecta erorile folosind codul Shore de 9 qubiți
începând cu erorile de inversare de bit care se mai numesc și erori X iată circuit-ul care efectuează
codificarea și doar pentru a ușura discuția vom gândi despre cei nouă qubiți pe care îi obținem din acest cod ca fiind
grupați în trei blocuri de câte trei qubiți unde fiecare bloc reprezintă codificarea pe care o obținem prin aplicarea
celui de-al doilea pas de codificare care este codul obișnuit de repetiție pe 3 biți acesta se numește codul intern în
acest context în timp ce codul extern este codul folosit pentru primul pas de codificare care în acest caz este versiunea modificată
a codului de repetiție pe trei biți care funcționează pentru erorile de inversare de fază pentru a corecta erorile de inversare de bit putem
pur și simplu trata fiecare bloc separat fiecare bloc este o codificare a unui qubit folosind codul de repetiție pe trei biți
și acel cod protejează împotriva erorilor de inversare de bit să presupunem mai întâi că o eroare X apare pe oricare dintre qubiți
cum ar fi qubitului din mijloc al blocului din mijloc dacă verificăm în mod independent fiecare dintre blocuri pentru erori de inversare de bit și
corectăm orice erori găsim atunci această eroare va fi corectată și codificarea originală va fi
recuperată de fapt am putea chiar să avem multiple erori X și tot să le corectăm în acest mod cu condiția că erorile sunt
în blocuri separate dacă am fi avut două sau trei erori X într-un singur bloc am fi în necaz dar
atâta timp cât există cel mult o eroare X pe bloc codul intern le va detecta și vom putea recupera starea codificată originală
deci corectarea erorilor de inversare de bit este o chestiune destul de simplă pentru acest cod trebuie de asemenea să luăm în considerare erorile de inversare de fază
sau cu alte cuvinte erorile Z de data asta nu este atât de clar ce ar trebui să facem deoarece codul extern este cel care
corectează erorile de inversare de fază dar nu putem detecta și corecta direct pentru că codul intern este cumva
WEBVTT
în cale dar vom vedea cum să facem asta în curând pentru a înțelege mai bine cum funcționează erorile X și Z
și efectele pe care le au în cadrul circuit-urilor cuantice este util să observăm câteva relații simple între aceste erori și gate-urile
controlled NOT și asta va fi de asemenea util într-o lecție ulterioară mai întâi să începem cu erorile X
sau gate-urile X și modul în care se raportează la gate-urile controlled NOT dacă aplicăm un gate X pe
qubitului țintă al unui controlled NOT și apoi aplicăm controlled NOT atunci asta este echivalent cu a schimba ordinea și a face mai întâi controlled NOT
pe de altă parte dacă aplicăm un gate X pe qubitului de control al unui controlled NOT și apoi aplicăm controlled NOT nu putem pur și simplu
schimba ordinea ci în schimb trebuie să aplicăm gate-ul X pe ambii qubiți și poți verifica toate aceste relații pe
cont propriu dacă dorești gândindu-te la ce se întâmplă cu stările bazei standard de exemplu situația este similară pentru erorile Z
cu excepția că rolurile qubiților de control și țintă se schimbă în particular dacă efectuăm un
gate Z pe qubitului de control al unui controlled NOT și apoi efectuăm controlled NOT atunci asta are același efect ca și efectuarea
gate-ului Z după controlled NOT dar dacă efectuăm gate-ul Z pe qubitului țintă în schimb atunci asta este
echivalent cu a efectua mai întâi controlled NOT și apoi a aplica un gate Z pe ambii qubiți și în final toate aceste
relații sunt simetrice în sensul că putem întotdeauna schimba ordinea gate-urilor de pe ambele părți ale fiecărei ecuații
ceea ce este echivalent cu a lua inversa sau transpusa conjugată a ambelor părți dat fiind că gate-urile X Z și controlled NOT
sunt toate propriile lor inverse acum să considerăm erorile de inversare de fază și cum le putem detecta și corecta
folosind codul Shore de 9 qubiți iată circuit-ul nostru de codificare și vom continua să gândim despre cei nouă
qubiți folosiți în codificare ca fiind grupați în trei blocuri de câte trei qubiți să presupunem că o eroare Z apare pe
oricare dintre qubiți cum ar fi cel indicat aici folosind ceea ce tocmai am observat despre gate-urile Z
și gate-urile controlled NOT asta este echivalent cu două erori Z înainte de controlled NOT una pe
controlul și una pe qubitului țintă și aceste erori se întâmplă să comute cu celălalt controlled NOT din bloc deci putem
schimba ordinea și iată ce obținem eroarea Z de jos nu face nimic deoarece acționează pe o stare zero
și putem glisa totul în continuare și obținem această diagramă deci ce am găsit este că o eroare Z undeva în
blocul din mijloc este echivalentă cu o eroare Z care apare pe qubitului din mijloc înainte de a doua fază de codificare și
poți raționa exact la fel pentru o eroare Z pe oricare dintre qubiți o inversare de fază pe orice qubit dintr-un bloc
este echivalentă cu o inversare de fază pe qubitului corespunzător înainte de codificarea internă și asta este destul de simplu și intuitiv dacă
te gândești la modul în care erorile Z afectează codul de repetiție pe trei biți deci o opțiune pentru a trata o eroare Z
este să decodificăm codul intern și apoi să detectăm și să corectăm erorile Z folosind codul extern care este versiunea modificată
a codului de repetiție pe 3 biți care poate corecta o eroare Z deci asta corectează eroarea noastră Z și
am putea re-codifica cu codul intern dacă am dori să facem asta putem de asemenea corecta erorile Z în
loc dacă vrei să spui fără a decoda și re-codifica și este destul de simplu dar pentru a explica cum putem
face asta vom avea nevoie de puțin mai mult spațiu să presupunem că decodificăm codul intern
și apoi calculăm sindromul pentru codul extern folosind aceeași metodă ca înainte unde implicăm doar cei trei qubiți din codul extern și
apoi re-codificăm ei bine putem simplifica toți acești controlled NOT puțin și de fapt
putem folosi relațiile între gate-urile NOT și gate-urile controlled NOT pe care tocmai le-am observat cu câteva momente în urmă pentru a ajuta cu această
sarcină și făcând asta putem economisi patru controlled NOT și acesta este circuit-ul pe care îl obținem dacă o eroare Z a apărut pe unul
dintre qubiți ce ne spune sindromul acum nu este care qubit a suferit o eroare Z ci mai degrabă în care bloc a apărut eroarea Z
dar asta este în regulă deoarece știm că nu contează care qubit dintr-un bloc suferă o eroare Z
efectul este același pentru toți cei trei qubiți din acel bloc și deci putem de fapt corecta eroarea Z aplicând un gate Z oricărui
qubit din acel bloc acesta apropo este un exemplu a ceea ce se numește degenerescență într-un cod
corector de erori unde nu identificăm în mod unic o eroare dată dar o putem corecta oricum în final să presupunem că atât o
inversare de bit cât și o eroare de inversare de fază apar posibil pe același qubit de exemplu să presupunem că o
inversare de bit și o eroare de inversare de fază se întâmplă pe acest qubit chiar aici după cum se dovedește aceste erori pot fi
detectate și corectate complet independent și de fapt nu contează dacă corectăm fiecare bloc pentru o
inversare de bit mai întâi și apoi corectăm pentru inversări de fază sau dacă o facem în ordine inversă pentru a vedea asta să observăm mai întâi
că ordinea acestor erori nu contează deci le putem inversa dacă dorim motivul pentru asta nu este că
X și Z comută deoarece nu comută X * Z este egal cu minus Z * X dar
factorul negativ 1 nu are niciun efect în această situație deoarece este o fază globală putem acum muta eroarea Z exact cum
am făcut mai înainte și în acest punct este evident că dacă mai întâi am corecta fiecare bloc pentru erorile X și apoi am corecta
pentru erorile Z atunci am fi corectat ambele erori alternativ dacă dintr-un motiv oarecare
am decide să corectăm mai întâi erorile Z am putea face asta și eroarea X nu are absolut niciun efect în acel proces
asta trebuie să fie adevărat deoarece în primul rând eroarea X comută cu fiecare gate din circuit-ul care calculează
sindromul pentru codul extern și în al doilea rând ordinea dintre eroarea X și gate-ul Z pe care îl aplicăm pentru a face
corecția nu contează exact cum am argumentat când gate-ul Z era o eroare deci asta permite corectarea erorii Z
și putem atunci corecta fiecare bloc pentru a elimina eroarea X deci ceea ce am argumentat este că
putem corecta o eroare X o eroare Z sau ambele pe oricare dintre qubiți folosind acest cod
de fapt putem corecta mai multe erori decât atât cum ar fi multiple erori X atâta timp cât cad în blocuri diferite
sau multiple erori Z atâta timp cât cel mult un bloc primește un număr impar de ele dar mergând mai departe ceea ce va fi cel mai relevant
este că putem corecta o eroare X o eroare Z sau ambele pe oricare un qubit și în ultima parte a lecției
vom vedea cum aceasta este de fapt suficient pentru a concluziona că acest cod poate corecta o eroare arbitrară pe oricare un
qubit înainte de a trece la ultima parte a lecției în care vom considera erori cuantice arbitrare vom discuta pe scurt
performanța codului Shore de N qubiți când erorile reprezentate de matricile Pauli apar aleatoriu pe
qubiți — pentru a fi mai concreți, să considerăm un model simplu de zgomot în care erorile apar independent pe qubiți
fiecare qubit suferind o eroare cu probabilitatea p și fără nicio corelație între erorile de pe qubiți diferiți
cel mai rău scenariu pentru codul Shore de 9 qubiți este că o eroare y — adică atât o eroare X, cât și o eroare Z —
apare pe fiecare qubit afectat, și vom presupune acest scenariu cel mai rău doar pentru a obține o margine
asupra performanței codului; dar ai putea considera, de exemplu, că cele trei erori Pauli sunt la fel de
probabile. Acum presupune că Q este un qubit într-o anumită stare pe care vrem să o protejăm împotriva erorilor și imaginează-ți că
avem opțiunea de a folosi codul Shore de 9 qubiți — ar trebui să îl folosim? Ei bine, răspunsul nu este neapărat
da, pentru că dacă există prea mult zgomot — adică p este prea mare — folosirea codului Shore ar putea de fapt înrăutăți lucrurile,
la fel cum am văzut la codul de repetiție când p este mai mare decât 1/2; dar dacă p este suficient de mic, atunci
răspunsul este da, ar trebui să folosim codul. Să vedem de ce este așa și ce înseamnă că p este prea mare sau suficient de mic
pentru acest cod. Codul Shore poate corecta orice eroare Pauli pe un singur qubit și, în cel mai rău
caz, în care erorile Pauli sunt erori y, asta înseamnă că codul protejează cu succes Q cu o probabilitate dată de
expresia afișată pe ecran. Mai precis, codul funcționează când nu există erori, iar asta se întâmplă
cu probabilitatea 1 minus p ^ 9, deoarece există nouă qubiți care trebuie să fie fiecare neafectați, și funcționează când există
exact o eroare; ținând cont că există nouă qubiți diferiți care ar putea fi afectați, asta se întâmplă cu probabilitatea 9 * P * 1 - p ^ 8
pe de altă parte, dacă nu ne-am osteni să folosim codul, singurul nostru qubit ar rămâne neafectat de o eroare cu
probabilitatea unu minus P. Deci codul ajută doar atunci când prima probabilitate este mai mare decât a doua,
deoarece aceste expresii reprezintă probabilitățile noastre de succes în cele două cazuri: când folosim codul și când nu
îl folosim. Iată un grafic al acestor două funcții pentru valori mici ale lui p și constatăm că punctul de echilibru apare la
aproximativ 3 și 3/4 la sută. Deci dacă p este mai mic decât această valoare, atunci codul
ajută. La punctul de echilibru, probabilitățile sunt egale, deci nu facem altceva decât să pierdem timpul împreună cu 8 qubiți dacă
folosim codul, dar altfel nu există niciun inconvenient; dincolo de acel punct, nu ar trebui să folosim deloc acest cod,
deoarece de fapt crește șansa unei erori pe qubitul codificat, pe care îl numim în mod obișnuit
qubit logic în acest context, și asta se întâmplă pur și simplu pentru că șansa a două sau mai multe erori pe nouă qubiți este
mai mare decât șansa unei singure erori pe un singur qubit, pentru valori ale lui p în acest interval. 3 și 3/4% poate nu pare foarte
bun, mai ales comparat cu 50%, care este punctul de echilibru analog pentru codul de repetiție de trei biți pentru
informația clasică; dar este mai greu să protejezi informația cuantică și, în plus, deși acest
cod reprezintă o descoperire strălucitoare — ca primul cod de corectare a erorilor cuantice — și se dovedește a fi excelent în scopuri pedagogice, faptul
este că pur și simplu nu este un cod prea bun în termeni practici. Până acum am considerat erori X
și erori Z în contextul codului Shore de 9 qubiți. Acum să considerăm erori arbitrare,
începând mai întâi cu erori unitare. Astfel, de exemplu, o astfel de eroare ar putea corespunde unei rotații foarte mici
a sferei Bloch, reprezentând posibil o eroare introdusă de un gate care nu este perfect, de pildă,
sau ar putea fi orice altă operație unitară pe un qubit, nu neapărat ceva apropiat de operația
identitate. S-ar putea părea că corectarea unor astfel de erori este dificilă — există infinit de multe erori posibile de
acest fel și este de neconceput că am putea identifica exact ce eroare este și să o anulăm. Dar nu
trebuie să facem nimic diferit față de ce am discutat deja: atâta timp cât putem corecta un bit flip, un phase flip sau ambele, vom
reuși de fapt să corectăm o eroare unitară arbitrară pe un singur qubit, și voi explica acum de ce este
așa. Mai întâi, la fel ca toate matricele 2x2, putem exprima o matrice unitară arbitrară
care reprezintă o eroare pe un singur qubit ca o combinație liniară a celor patru matrice Pauli, inclusiv matricea
identitate. Apropo, după cum ai putut observa, folosesc X, Y și Z cu majuscule pentru a denota matricele Pauli non-identitate
și voi continua să fac asta pentru restul acestei serii — este convențional în corectarea erorilor cuantice și, de asemenea,
face lucrurile puțin mai ușor de citit în acest context. De asemenea, va fi convenabil să folosim indici pentru a indica pe care
qubit acționează o anumită operație unitară pe un qubit. Deci, de exemplu, dacă folosim convenția de numerotare a qubiților din
Qiskit, începând de la qubitul zero pe dreapta, atunci avem expresiile afișate pe ecran pentru
diverse operații unitare pe qubiți individuali, unde în fiecare caz facem produsul tensorial al matricei unitare cu matricea identitate
pe fiecare alt qubit. Deci, în special, putem exprima UK — adică U aplicat qubitului K — ca aceeași
combinație liniară ca înainte, cu excepția că fiecare matrice Pauli este aplicată qubitului K. Nu trebuie să ne batem capul cu
indicele pentru identitate, de altfel — înțelegerea here este că aceasta este identitatea pe toți
qubiții. Acum presupune că |ψ⟩ este codificarea unui qubit în 9 qubiți. Dacă eroarea U apare pe
qubitul k, obținem U_k * |ψ⟩, pe care îl putem exprima ca o combinație liniară de operații Pauli acționând pe |ψ⟩, care
desigur este doar |ψ⟩ în cazul identității. În acest moment, va fi util să observăm că matricea Pauli Y
este egală cu i * X * Z, deci putem face acea substituție în expresia noastră.
Deci această eroare a avut loc și acum presupune că încercăm să o corectăm folosind aceeași procedură ca
înainte. Primul pas este să calculăm sindromul, care în cazul codului Shore are 8 biți lungime — doi biți pentru fiecare din
cele trei ori în care folosim codul interior, împreună cu doi biți suplimentari pentru codul exterior — dar nu contează cu adevărat, putem să ne gândim la el ca la un
șir de lungime fixă. Iată o descriere a stării pe care o obținem imediat înainte de măsurarea sindromului, unde fiecare
sindrom reprezintă cei opt biți obținuți din eroarea Pauli corespunzătoare. Observă în acest moment că cele două
sisteme sunt corelate în general și, de fapt, aceasta este cheia pentru a face totul să funcționeze: prin măsurarea sindromului,
ce vom face efectiv este să colapsăm starea în una în care una dintre cele patru operații Pauli a fost aplicată
qubitului k din |ψ⟩, și vom ști din sindrom care operație Pauli a fost, deci o putem corecta dacă
este necesar. În particular, dacă măsurăm sindromul și facem corecția corespunzătoare, obținem o stare de
forma afișată pe ecran, care în mod esențial este o stare produs. Avem codificarea noastră originală necoruptă ca
factor tensorial din dreapta — aceasta este cea mai importantă — și pe stânga avem o matrice de densitate σ care
descrie un sindrom de eroare aleatoriu, dar nu mai există nicio corelație cu sistemul care ne interesează, adică
cel din dreapta, deoarece erorile au fost corectate. În acest moment putem arunca qubiții sindromului sau îi putem reseta în
caz că vrem să îi folosim din nou, și asta este de fapt destul de important, deoarece acesta este modul în care aleatorietatea sau entropia
generată de erori este eliminată din sistem, și acesta este modul în care funcționează discretizarea erorilor — cel puțin pentru erorile unitare.
În esență, prin măsurarea sindromului, proiectăm efectiv eroarea pe o eroare descrisă de
o matrice Pauli. La prima vedere, poate părea prea frumos să fie adevărat că putem corecta erori unitare arbitrare
în acest fel — chiar și erori minuscule, aproape imperceptibile în sine. Dar ceea ce este important de înțeles
este că aceasta este o eroare unitară pe un singur qubit și, prin designul codului, o operație pe un singur qubit nu poate schimba
starea qubitului logic codificat — tot ce poate face este să mute starea în afara spațiului de codificări valide,
dar corecțiile o aduc înapoi exact unde era. În final, să considerăm ce se întâmplă
când apare o eroare arbitrară, nu neapărat unitară. Configurația este aceeași ca înainte:
am codificat un qubit în 9 folosind codul Shore și o eroare arbitrară reprezentată de un canal de qubit φ
apare pe unul dintre qubiți. După cum vom vedea, totul va funcționa practic în același mod
ca pentru erorile unitare, și primul pas pentru a verifica acest lucru este să considerăm o reprezentare Kraus a erorii noastre.
Ce putem face acum este să urmăm exact același raționament ca pentru erorile unitare, cu excepția că aplicăm acel
raționament la matricele Kraus în loc de o singură matrice unitară care reprezintă o eroare.
În particular, fiecare matrice Kraus poate fi exprimată ca o combinație liniară de matrice Pauli, și asta ne permite să
exprimăm acțiunea acestei erori φ pe orice qubit K de care se leagă, în forma afișată pe
ecran. Tot ce facem de fapt este să dezvoltăm matricele Kraus ca combinații liniare de matrice
Pauli. Dacă apoi calculăm și măsurăm sindromul de eroare și corectăm orice erori dezvăluite, vom obține o
stare similară cu cea din cazul erorii unitare. Nu voi trece prin detalii — totul este destul de similar cu cazul unitar
și, de asemenea, puțin mai dezordonat de scris, dar din punct de vedere conceptual este destul de
simplu. Ar trebui să menționez că toate acestea se generalizează la alte coduri de corectare a erorilor cuantice, inclusiv coduri care pot corecta erori pe mai mulți
qubiți. Într-un astfel de caz, erorile pe mai mulți qubiți pot fi exprimate ca combinații liniare de produse tensoriale de matrice
Pauli, și, corespunzător, diferitele sindroame posibile vor descrie corecții efectuate pe mai mulți qubiți, nu doar pe unul
singur; dar ideea de bază este exact aceeași. Din nou, prin măsurarea sindromului,
proiectăm sau colapsăm efectiv erorile într-un set discret de posibilități reprezentate de produse tensoriale
de matrice Pauli, și corectând acele erori — adică erorile Pauli — putem recupera starea originală
codificată. Între timp, orice aleatorietate generată în proces este transferată în qubiții sindromului, pe care îi putem
elimina sau reseta — lucru esențial, deoarece acesta este modul în care entropia generată de erori și de măsurătorile sindromului este
eliminată din sistem. Și acesta este sfârșitul lecției în care am aruncat o primă privire asupra
corectării erorilor cuantice, inclusiv codul Shore de 9 qubiți și discretizarea erorilor. Sper că te vei alătura mie la
lecția următoare, în care vom discuta formalismul stabilizatorilor, care ne oferă un instrument puternic pentru a descrie și
analiza o clasă largă și interesantă de coduri de corectare a erorilor cuantice, inclusiv unele care sunt candidați promițători pentru
calculatoare cuantice reale. La revedere până atunci!